trump's consigliary rudy uh giuliani had
a bet
he had a bad week new york new york
state listen
suspended rudy's law license
is that personal for you sir tim seemed
very personal to this man over there
no rudy cannot practice law in new york
and to add insult to injury from now on
all of his personal and financial
decisions have to be made by britney
spears dad
so that's bad but uh oh brittany
no i don't usually comment on these pop
culture stories but britney spears was
uh
you know a lot of people looking at was
in court this week speaking for the
first time she's 39 years old she wants
to be
free of her father who controls
every aspect of her life
you know i mean going back to 2008 yes
she did go we all remember that with the
shaved head and the umbrella and she did
go a little nuts but
who hasn't shaved their head and
attacked people with an umbrella at one
point
you know it was a long time ago and now
he's 39 years old and the father
everything she can't spend money to
decide when to go out decide who to see
i mean [ __ ] we let someone completely
unstable run the country for four years
i think she could get a credit card
uh and yes
freedom this week's all about
freedom free britney and there was a
[ __ ]
i love this story at the supreme court
no less a high school cheerleader named
brandi
levy wrote on snapchat a couple of years
ago
[ __ ] school [ __ ] softball [ __ ]
cheer [ __ ] everything and for some
reason this is a free speech case it
reached the supreme court they had to
decide and the supreme court did the
right thing
in a case of brandy versus whatever i
guess was the name of this trial
uh they said yes brandy can get out
there and say
[ __ ] cheer [ __ ] [ __ ] school [ __ ]
everybody
so brandi was thankful she thanked the
court and then told the [ __ ] at the
girl scouts they can shove the cookies
up their ass
freedom oh
and here is here is some more freedom
the state of connecticut became the 19th
state now to legalize recreational
marijuana this week
i'll tell you
if this stuff gets any more popular i'm
gonna have to try it
i hear good things
and another freedom we have the first
out gay nfl player this is apra yeah i
mean
apropos of what i was saying a couple of
weeks ago about you know we have we're
not there anywhere we have still have
work to do in things but
a lot of progress has been made we're
we've come a long way baby and other
you know he came out and even five years
ago this wouldn't have happened all the
other players congratulated him they
said they were proud of him the teams
did the coaches did
the nfl did and uh this player carl
nasib he said he was
living a lie it was just too difficult
and it was hard enough having every week
to appear with 10 other guys in the same
outfit
i think that i think the team did know
that he was gay because
one time he went into that tent for the
uh you know the
concussion protocol that they do and the
trainer asked him what day is it how
many fingers am i holding up and
what year was the wizard of oz made
i think they knew so uh that's the
that's the plus side of the freedom
ledger on the bad side
you know too bad senate republicans have
done it they blocked the voting rights
bill that the democrats were putting
forward
mitch mcconnell said it was a thinly
veiled ploy for free and fair elections
democracy dies in darkness they say no
it dies in the senate